today introduce the speaker and so I can
start introducing speak right away
all right so next up for this Christian
Nick and I will continue on this recent
program
easy-peasy thank you very much thanks a
organizers for inviting me to talk here
thanks for the opportunity is about
recent progress that I made with a two
of my students and in this direction of
finding finding multiplicity of
selections and finding out if there are
multiple easy obstructions so I want I
want to start with a recap so we've
heard this I mean we've heard about this
with that number one now a significant
number of times in the workshop but I
mean I want to have at least a tiny bit
of self containment in this story and
not just jumping not just jump
completely avoid all right so that let
me actually take some time now to say
again these these problems that we are
looking at so that's the determinant
right our favorite determinant and well
and then there's the permanent and let's
have a look at so we've seen this kind
of action before you get some linear map
here you can think of this as an N
squared by N squared matrix and you can
define what what what what G times dead
end be well I mean this is the identity
matrix and this is just that determinant
but it might yeah you might move it
around you do base change say if Jesus
and invertible matrix is a base change
but yeah it gives you some other
polynomial here G dot n so and yeah so
that that kind of firm definition we've
seen several times so you might ignore
the transpose here just for technical
purposes right so if in general if
somebody gives you a polynomial here you
get a different polynomial but by
applying some matrix set all right and
then it's just your old polynomial but
not evaluated at your original point but
evaluated at like G times your point
right so it gives you a different
polynomial new polynomial but then we
think of this new polynomial is having
if this was invertible then it should be
the same complexity right so that's what
we think of and now we redefine the set
here by applying all matrices and well
turns out that this has a very nice
description that is just
all determinants of n-by-n matrices and
the entries are homogeneous linear
polynomials and now this is this is this
four bit here and for example that one
here this this polynomial here can be
written as a 2x2 as a determinate of a 2
by 2 matrix and the anti sour or
homogeneous linear and therefore we say
it's in this in this orbitty is in the
c-4 before that too and indeed you will
find that 4 by 4 matrix that actually
gives you this this polynomial right so
again you can read it out from from
these linear forms you will get a four
by four matrix well I'm not gonna it's
not so important how this is like I mean
these are these are formalities is not
so quite so important right so various
results shows that you can always find
some end so that if you take the
permanent that you pad it properly then
you find that it is expressible in this
way so will I in this set here it will
be the homogeneous version of classical
variance we saw it okay and so what you
usually do and we will see also why you
do it is that you close the set so from
this perspective of algebraic geometry
if you close it so taking all the limit
points and adding them to your set now
this is an algebraic variety and so and
you can replace now the set of all n
square by n square matrices actually by
the general linear group so making this
a group of closure and I will have a lot
of advantages to look at this set here
as a group orbit closure we will see so
we can now define in a very natural way
this DC underscore here as for the
permanent as a smallest n such that your
parrot permanent lies in this group
orbit closure okay so now this digiti
conjecture that we've heard about
several times now at this this notion
this is the border determinant to
complexity I mean one way of defining a
border determinant of complexity it
grows super polynomially okay and so the
key observation that was also greater
was also pointing this out but this is
the key observation that makes this
whole thing work is that your point lies
now in this orbit closure if and only if
the whole orbit closure is contained in
this other in their determinant or
right because an arbitrage is a small
set that's closed topologically and also
closed under the group operation but
this now makes the whole thing going
because now you want to prove lower
bounds you want to disprove that the
point lies in the over closure but you
can actually do this by comparing
properties of two varieties so you have
a variety on the left hand side the
right hand side you just want to prove
that one doesn't line the other we can
do this for example with a very weak
lower bound technique here varieties for
example have a dimension right so if you
folks into the dimension on the
permanent side exceeds that I mentioned
on the determinants that you cannot have
this sitting inside here all right and
then therefore this means by definition
now I'm you use this if and only if here
this point is an ID lying here and this
gives you a lower bound on the
determinant on the border determinant of
complexity of the permanent right so
anyway of separate of some are trying to
prove that this does not lie inside so
so algebraic geometers use more we find
have more refined notions actually I
don't use dimension so they they study
the functions that live on these
varieties so that this and those are
called coordinate rings and the
varieties I studied in algebraic
geometry by studying the coordinate
rings so what are what are those rings
so I'm let me define the set that we are
working in those are just homogeneous
TBN polynomials and capital n variables
you can think of capital n s a little N
squared and then this determinant is in
there and you think of the determinant
as it's say it's coefficient vector as a
point in this space okay and it's lies
in there so there's some finite
dimensional vector space this is its
dimension here and now we want to look
at polynomials on this space okay you're
looking at and we denote it by this one
this is a polynomial is a polynomial
ring so this is a polynomial ring it's
how much is the you deep component so
this would be homogeneous degree D
polynomials in this many variables so
and yeah so this is the canonical
classical example that you usually use
if you have yeah I mean if you got less
than the other talks that we're talking
about these things and this is this will
get you back on the track certainly so
and just look at poly to see to does up
this has a basis of just x squared XY Y
squared and now everybody know me that
can be expressed in this nice form a
square
expect let's see why squid and now you
want you want to have in this course so
the core everybody know me here you
think of it as a point as its
coefficient vector ABC and now you're
looking at polynomials in ABC alright so
you would say a degree D degree two
polynomials in ABC as I get this basis
here a squared a B AC P squared P C C
squared and and you are asking for what
kind of functions are in here so for
example there's the discriminant in
there that's b squared minus 4ac lives
is such a polynomial and it's vanishing
set is actually interesting so if P
squared minus 4ac is actually zero and
this means that you can take a
polynomial it has a very special
property it means that there will be
some come some coefficients alpha and
beta such that your polynomial can be
written as SS square can be condensed so
it's a very special form so if you want
to for example then disprove that your
that your polynomial has the simple form
alright so you can think of this as a
complexity lower bound right so you
disprove that they're current that your
polynomial has this special format then
you just take a point O me you evaluate
P squared minus 4ac if it's nonzero you
get a lower bound on your complexity
right there you prove this proved that
it had that it can be nicely written in
this way in the sixteenth way all right
and there is an action of of the general
linear group on on this on your corded
ring now so it's not only that your
group moves your points around it's also
that your that this group action lifts
to the function so if you have some
function for example you can ask is my
is my function in an invariant for
example connecting this to invariant
theory right and then so this action is
defined in exactly in the same way so
your new polynomial evaluated at some
point is your 0.0 me over it at this G
transpose point right so transpose again
just for technical reasons so now yeah
so in particular you can think of
invariance for example and so what's the
corner doing now so if you if you have
some subset here you can think of this
as say the determinant orbit all right Z
being the determinant orbit or the
parrot permanent orbit then you can
define the coordinate ring of its
closure so as just you taking all
functions and you risk
that do mine of definition to to the to
this z-bar okay just you had a lot of
functions and now you're just a very
good doing them at Z bar some of them
will now be the same function right and
in particular if Y bar if you find some
Y bar that are sitting inside Z bar not
we wanted to actually we have having to
orbit closures right we want to compare
them so if there's one of them Y by
sitting inside Z bar and this gives a
very natural surjection now of these
rings so those are rings yeah so
polynomials where the domain of
definition is restricted to Z bar and
now you restrict even further to Y bar
right so this is a surjection of
functions and yeah in a natural way now
your Z bar the Z was that we will
consider they would be closed under the
action of the general linear group so
and then this net in a natural way lifts
also actually to the to these functions
this would be they would have an action
why exactly this action that we had here
we will also have the action on all
these coordinate wings that will you see
so all our quadratics they will see
there will have the natural action of
the general linear group in all our
cases and okay so going back to this
what we actually want to prove that's
this orbit closure we want to prove that
this overcomes it doesn't sit in this
over closure right for permit permit
doesn't sit in the determinant so yeah I
mean we've just seen if it does then
there is a natural restriction here or
functions so functions on on that one
over closure and the other by just
further restricting the domain of
definition and this actually holds also
in any finite degree D if you want to so
still degree D function if you restrict
the domain of definition further still
degree D and so now you have a this
group action here on what are finite
dimensional vector spaces so this is
actually just a finite dimensional
vector space with a group action on it
and this one is also finite dimensional
vector space with a group action on it
alright so for example you could yeah so
you could ask so how many invariants
does this does this contain say there's
say this much for example have SL n
squared invariants
right and this one might also and you
say you want to count those right and so
this decomposition that I wrote here is
the decomposition into irreducible and
this is more it is a more refined way
it's just not not
counting invariance it's counting all
kinds of different types of irreducible
representations so they're not only
invariance they're also all kinds of
other irreducible and they are all
indexed by some lambdas here and there's
lambdas are these these partitions these
young diagrams right and yeah so and
some of them might appear more often
slave I mean it is not clear that
there's a unique invariant it could be
several invariants for example in here
so this is what is called the
multiplicity of lambda in this in this
homogeneous degree D component of the
score in a drink okay you get it exactly
the same way you get multiplicities of
these coordinate drinks in the exactly
the same way so one of those
multiplicities for example is the
dimension of the invariant space and
well and the nice property is now that
when you if you have such an inclusion
here then for every lambda you will have
that the multiplicity on the determinant
side is at least the multiplicity on the
on the permanent site and so in a sense
of measures size of your orbit closures
right and therefore now if you find some
lambda where the multiplicity on the
determinant side is less strictly less
than the one on the permanent size that
gives you a lower bound on the
determinant to the complexity of the
permanent and this is called a
multiplicity obstruction and if you find
ya if you find that this being 0 on the
determinant site then this is called an
occurrence obstruction ok yes sure I
should go ahead I mean you can you know
if there are no obstructions you cannot
at this point we don't know how to
conclude right so we would like to have
a theorem that tells us that separation
can always be achieved with these kinds
of obstructions where we know that
that's false in general in generality
right so we need but it might be true in
some but if you have additional
properties on your points this might say
things like this might be true
I mean with it's false in generality
yeah I mean you can take for example if
you take two generic points then they
would have the same they would have the
same coordinate ring no they're not have
they were not like some of acquired
rings yes so you want to have something
you want to have some you want to use
some special properties of your points
to have a hope that this works and
usually what what what we think should
be a good property is that this is
character that the points are
characterized by their symmetries by
their stabilizers and you will see maybe
where this intuition comes from that we
want to have these properties there and
no contour examp is known in a setting
where these points are actually
characterized by the stabilizers so so
there that something like this might be
true okay there are no occur so
structures for in this there no
occurrence obstructions for the term
invest permanent right so the roof
relies heavily on the padding of the
permanent and one can replace the
determinant by the homogenous iterated
matrix multiplication to avoid this and
I spent quite a significant amount of
time in the bootcamp talk to talk about
this right so you just watch it on those
lectures and I explained exactly the
model of computation is somewhat genius
and it's beautiful a nice yes sorry this
lady you heard this notation Polly it's
here yes how does that fit with these
example of GL and square
this is yeah so here your your GL n so
this is an N squared + GL + dead end
sits inside podían C N squared
it's a sub priety here podían CNS the a
is you can think of poly and CNS the
ambient space for everything everything
lifts and Darren is a is your point
gr N squared n is your orbit it's it's
is a subset of podían C capital n
capital and here you can think of
capital n SN square now because he also
have a gia capital and the next side you
have a G a little N squared it's good
all right and I saw summaries you can if
you can compare these two matrices and
you get a lower bound of course
obstructionist even stronger there are
no such of cross instructions and the
proof who relies on padding right so
that's the summary of part one and I
want to tell you that something about a
good news that there are actually group
varieties you can you can cook up that
cannot be separated with occurrence of
selections but you can actually separate
them with multiplicity of structures
right and this is joint work with my
students early on to our client and
click upon OVA and this is also setting
without any padding okay but it's a toy
sitting I mean this is thick this is not
even the toy setting that we were
talking about outside so far this is not
back watering this is the toy setting of
toy settings so and but anyway and even
there you cannot have occurs of
structures so so that way it shows the
significant weakness of occurrence of
swatches so the two varieties are the
following you take we just got the child
variety sometimes and it's just if your
polynomial can be written as a product
of homogeneous linear forms and it's in
the charity okay this is already closed
so I didn't draw the closure here and so
now you switch the I switched here the
the group the Google's of GL little m
okay it's not build and not not clear
capital and anymore it's like little m
now
and the second variety is the variety of
Bora Waring ranked at most K polynomials
is just you have your polynomials and
they can be written as a sum of K many
and powers of homogeneous linear forms
and those are your two varieties so the
powerful set so you want to show that
that you cannot is called factorizing
power son so that you want to show that
that you cannot embed this set here so
this is of course not
this is why I said toy setting of toy
setting because obviously I mean widely
knowing that you if for any reasonable
set of parameters if you have a power so
it's it's not you can't factorize it
that's not a product of homogeneous
linear forms but you can prove it
actually with multiplicity obstructions
okay so
it's not so obvious that you can write
and so we don't know much of what is
object so you pick any reasonable
setting Eminem there and you you fix K
and D to be M plus 1 and this is an
explicit lambda it's n square minus 2 n
2 is an explicit construction of an
obstruction then you actually have an
inequality of modulus this year and this
shows that you cannot embed this one
variety in the other and of course you
can show this what other means is not
very difficult but ok but we can also
show that not in all cases but we can
show that in a finite case we can set
this up and compute do a computer
calculations and actually prove here
there are no occurrence obstructions in
this setting right you fix your
parameters and this kind of is the same
set up here you got a 7 here you got an
8 so you can actually separate these two
but for all I'm you whenever this is
positive on this side this will also be
positive
no of course of structures even it's
very simple I mean this is a very low
dimensional thing and and even here for
this very small setup there are no
occurrence obstructions and this was a
significant computer calculation so it
actually required us to implement new
algorithms for I show you in a second ok
let me show you how do we prove that
there are no I mean this is now a finite
set up right and I'd like to generalize
this but we don't know exactly yet how
to do it but we want to show if some new
occurs on this coordinate ring here this
is actually better more general
statement so this says if some you of
course at all in the corner doing of the
ambient space then already though um you
of course in the corner ring of the CH
alrighty so this is a bit of dirt more
more powerful statement that we have
here and we make use now of the
semigroup properties that you've seen
now in these two talks so and they hold
a very high generality so they also hold
in our set up here so your muse remember
your muse that we have here this is gia
3 just so it's just three numbers years
and mu 1 is greater or equal to mu 2 is
greater or equal to mu 3 ok and and you
take so the semi good properties the
properties say you take two partitions
and if if if they occur if they both
occur in the quarry ring then
some which is just the component-wise
summation of the two also is in the
corner drink and it doesn't work only
for this wandering also works for that
corner drink
same set up right it says in in other
words and more fancy words it says the
mules that occur in the corner drink and
the muse that occur in this core drink
those of semigroups ok that's what it
says and now how would you show that if
if if whenever am you of course in this
ring then it also of course in that ring
so what we do is we compute we compute
it are the 89 generators that actually
that happen to be in this semi group so
this means whenever you have anything
that happens to be here and it's a it's
a sum if I had some of these generators
here I find out some of these these
partitions and then for each generator
we actually showed that they were
actually occur that and they would do
something actually of course in this
corner drink we did this with a
significant computer calculation so
actually to redo basically there's a new
algorithmic approach to these these
occurrences here but anyway this is not
so important but yeah and it shows this
result okay it shows that there are no
of course obstructions here you cannot
have any yes no I certainly I mean this
is yeah you should I mean if you have
some conjectures you should back them up
right okay so and here multiplicity yes
no I did have intuitions why there's a
so yeah I mean I'm working on these
things for quite some time
okay so also this particular one here is
not just anything so this is something
that comes this is one type of so-called
Brits equations for the chopper AIA T is
one of the types that of course there
and it's one the one that's closest to
two to the things that Arturo right and
then so it gets easiest to analyze it
yeah how would you now show I mean so
there are of course obstructions but we
do want to have much procedure
obstructions so how do you do we do
something like that so and this is a
setup that works also in higher
generality so it's not actually limited
to just these two varieties so it's a
it's a it works in higher generality but
here we could actually push it to the
end all right so we want to show that
this is less than that and so the proof
works so first of all you want to have
some lower bar on this multiplicity and
some upper bound on that one here so so
for this lower bound on that one here we
just we show that in this specific setup
it's the Maxima multiplicity that you
could possibly hope for and then we
should show that this one is not
maximally large so what do I mean by
maximally large this incorrect stop
already this coefficient appeared is the
Platinum coefficient which is the
multiplicity that arises if you take the
corded ring of the hole ambient space
right so that's this means that all your
might be seized this one here and also
that one they are upper bound it always
by this a lambda d n this is a this an
upper part you can never go beyond that
because these two are yeah those are
separate ease of your ambient space you
can never go beyond yes so here this
would be exactly here as you say as you
see this would be exactly a and here we
don't we don't know but the gap is at
least one so you will see that you I'm
not saying I'm not saying that as a
check but I'm not ruling out a large gap
right I'm not ruling out that there
might be a large gap I do not determine
this I will only determine an upper
bound for this okay
it's also shows lower bumps for for sums
of cha varieties so for them to refill
keep sincerity
ah okay let's let's discuss this case
the number of summons that you have it's
it's K many summons of homogeneous
linear forms yeah and you you take them
and variables yes that's that's that
variety yes
here's no K because it's just one
summand it's just one more room here
basically sir it's a lot of homogeneous
linear forms and that one is a summoned
it's a sum of k many and it's the same
degree it's the same number of variables
just a sum of sum of powers of
homogeneous linear forms
okay also we proved in the paper in this
2016 paper that Peter was talking about
that if you're okay is at least the
degree D then this multiplicity here is
actually maxes out and you can say this
in other words that that this set here
is a hitting set for degree at most k
polynomials yes
this bubble NM k is equal to poly in
seen poly you know it's not no it is not
equal no it is it depends so this works
only because lambda is of this specific
has has actually few boxes this is
because the degree that of lambda is
this gives you a degree function that
cannot distinguish between pow and
actually the whole ambient space so yeah
I mean it would also be true if you make
a very large then you get the whole MA
space then it's still true but yeah we
don't have to do that okay so what is
what remains to show is that now you
have actually this is not maxed out okay
for the chava righty you have something
that is that is not maxed out so how
would you do such a thing
so you do it as follows okay so this
remains to show for your travel ready
this is not maximal as a set up and we
use an inheritance theorem which so we
connect this so it's known by an by
inheritance some inheritance theorem
that this is basically this much bliss T
of this lambda here is the multiplicity
of a lambda but now your group action
this was a GLM action but you can
actually replace this by a property at N
and you take the orbit closure of of
this monomial here like in Pascal c'mon
stop you at this orbit of the GL GL of
x1 up to xn why detective closure and
those are the same explicity so that's
no one and now this is another closure
problem and you can actually study it by
looking at its orbit so this is now
maybe a bit a misleading notation but if
you if you take the corner drink often
orbit so the orbit is not closed then
this is interpret in a different way so
this is called this is these are
actually rational functions that are
defined everywhere on your orbit so this
I in particular you get all the
functions that you had before but now
you might be able you can actually
divide by functions that I defined
everywhere on the
so you get an inclusion here of Rick's
okay so you just said this are not all
these are not all polynomials there
might be read some rational functions in
there and usually there are rational
functions in there so in particular but
still everything is nice we have group
actions and everything and
multiplicities and you get an upper
bound here from there's given by this
object so why on earth would you do this
and go through the lengths of now
actually trying to deal with rational
functions it's because there is actually
so this object here and this much pieces
can be nicely described so this much
bliss T here is just the dimension so
this is an irreducible representation
representation of type lambda and you
take H invariants inside there so H is
the stabilizer of the product X 1 up to
X n also Pascal qohor mentioned that
already right so what is the stabilizer
so you can yeah
so yes it's it's this group and and you
have to see reduce my we know exactly
how these you reduce will look like it's
an irreducible gln representation of a
specific type Lyman and you're just
asking how many what is the dimension of
the H invariant space and so in a lot of
cases this can be actually answered in
in this case here this is actually a
pleasant coefficient so this is we are
just very very lucky in this case then
we have an answer here note though that
this is a different Platinum coefficient
than that one because the D and the N is
subtly exchanged to order okay it's a
complete miracle that this appears here
but so on the proof of this fact is of
it is a very general proof using
algebraic Peter why through Romania
so this geometric invariant theory
algebraic petabyte theorem shows you
that you can you can actually get such a
nice description of this multiplicity
and now once we had once we have
established this factor we can actually
say okay let's have a look at this
lambda the specific one and let's
compare this this big ambient
multiplicity here with the one that's
our upper bound right and indeed there
we we can actually prove a gap of one
here okay and this is pair proof based
on symmetric functions so you actually
completely remove the whole geometry
from there and this is completely based
on on symmetric function research your
functions and things like this
and yeah so this now gives us the
desired bounce right so you have a your
multiplicity the Chow variety is it's
the same as in the orbit close it gives
you this upper bound here this can be
nicely described as just the splat
doesn't co-efficient indeed less than
the other present coefficient and the
separate all right so summary is that
yes oh yeah you have it actually no
quantity so therefore you separate these
two varieties and the proof is based on
a relationship between the orbit and the
orbit closure all right so there's this
inequality here so this is upper bound
this is interesting work and in the
finite case we verified that yeah you
cannot do this actually with of course
of selections but multiplicity of
selections work so now having such an
upper bound is of course an eye is a
nice thing and sometimes gives you
something interesting but we do we do
want to connect these these two objects
close so in particularly there's a lower
part missing here I mean yeah so the
upper part is just not it's not it's not
good enough I mean if you want to yeah
you have these two multiplicities in
this corner doing of orbit closures so
for one you need an upper bound for the
other one you need a lower bond alright
this is not it doesn't give a lower
point you'll remember the lower part we
just got because this was just a full
multiplicity alright so therefore we
need maybe some more sophisticated thing
here will give us some more insights
into what are exactly these
multiplicities in the coordinate drinks
of orbit closures so and this is the
work with my student
Umaga tan Kandaswamy where we try to
connect the orbits were their closures
as close as we can possibly try to
connect them and so the Stars lover
would work with both Peter that about
connection of the orbits and over
closure so the paper chord fundamental
invariance of orbit closures so you
start by taking what we're looking at a
different a different variety now that's
because in this variety it actually
works nicely so let's look at the
variety x1 so you look at the orbit
closure of just this this power son here
right to them I wrote this out just so
that everybody's again on the same page
what are these alrighty so this over
closure here and you take you take an
invariant
and som invariant here in on this on
this variety and yeah in particular
since this thing exists this means that
this is not under Nikon right there so
what this is actually the point is
actually stable and things like this and
anyway you take this fee and it turns
out that this this function here this
invariant is is nonzero everywhere on
the orbit is actually at photos directly
form from its invariants actually it's
nonzero everywhere on the orbit but but
if we study it further and we look where
does it vanish if we look so that the
whole orbit closure it's nonzero
everywhere on the orbit but it turns out
that it vanishes on the boundary so it
exactly exactly on all those points on
the boundary I mean I what side of that
we just don't really care right so it's
just we're looking at the closure and
inside the closure that's the orbit and
the vanishing set of our invariant is
exactly the boundary and yes so proof
uses a hey Birdman for criterion and as
a result we get that these two rings are
actually much closer related than we had
on the previous slide this ring is
actually just a localization of that
ring so what does that mean so you take
this invariant and now you you take the
string here and it's in this element
from the ring and you are allowed to
divide by arbitrary powers of this
invariant and you will end up with this
ring here so this is the only thing so
you you are so remember this were all
rational functions but actually the
denominators are just powers of V here
and this connections might connect sits
very closely so this is a corollary of
this fact immediate corollary so
whenever you have some degree D function
here then you can you can multiply it by
some power of the of your invariant this
is this map gamma here much bearing with
some power and make it to make it
actually a proper function in the
cordoning of the closure make it
actually come from a polynomial looks
like a polynomial now and this is just
this inclusion here is just your usual
inclusion that we have seen before right
so this is just sitting inside here
because you have rational functions on
that well there is this gamma here and
now so you we are interesting in the
question so what kind of power do you
need
actually to to make this work and so the
theorem is that this for the power sum
and we don't know anything about
anything else at this moment at this
point but for the power sum this is
really really small so if somebody gives
you a function here then the required
exponent is just M plus 4 D over N which
is which is really really really small
and connects these two this I mean
basically squeezes this this object here
from the left and from the right and
yeah and let me so let me maybe show you
give you an idea of how one could even
prove such a thing that this is so close
okay so this is a restatement of the two
things okay so how would we how are we
going to such a thing so we have
actually construction principles that
give us elements in these coordinate
drinks here in this one on on that one
and actually yeah but so and I work with
the on tables so you're starting with
the young tableau and you construct and
and there's a procedure coming from
representation theory that constructs
you a function here in this coordinate
ring so it's a it's a pretty limited
procedure so you might end up for
example with the zero polynomial and you
might not even know that you that you do
this and this was very hard to to figure
out what is happening doing this
construction process but you can but we
know that all highest weight functions
so I didn't define what it is but just
yeah ignore highest rate functions you
can also think of that our functions can
be constructed in this way right but we
just
in particular we don't know of yeah we
can't infer much but we can what we can
do is we have some way of evaluating
these functions at at specific points
this is right back to yes so you can
explicitly construct this F T and
there's the highest let it so this has
been a this has appeared actually in
several of our publications so far it's
a construction process from young
tablo's to highest right back to us yes
and there's a community uses
combinatorics in some little linear
Moochie linear algebra to evaluate at
specific points so it might but we don't
know I mean we don't know much
we can infer much from this but there's
a similar situation here for the
cornering of the orbit and that is not
very surprising so if you have given a
young tableau and that's now called s
you can explicitly construct now also
this is where also FS would be a highest
weight function in this corner during of
the orbit and why is this not surprising
because these objects you where you take
the H invariants are actually given
already by young tableaus right so this
is a this is not a very surprising
construction that something like this is
there and also in this case in the same
way all highest weight functions can be
constructed in exactly this way coming
from these young tablo's and there's
also we have a similar not exactly the
same but a similar and combinatorial in
your algebra way of evaluating at points
so this is this holds not only for this
specific point here of the power son but
this holds actually in higher generality
but for the power some these two these
two these two ways of evaluating at
points are very very close to each other
seem like almost being the same and and
therefore we can actually take a tableau
s and we construct it from that at
slightly larger table T such as these
two things here that we get or they
coincide on the whole SL orbit all right
so this means that yeah so given I mean
so given a function here it somehow
comes from some tableau s right and and
then you you construct now a slightly
larger tableau T in here but but the
function will on the whole SL orbit will
be exactly the same so the only
difference is like a multiplying by a
power here and the slightly larger
tableau T means from the slightly larger
store this difference of sizes of the
table so you can read up how large this
exponent actually is this is a
representation theorem
property okay yeah I don't want to go
into the this I mean you it boils down
to a completely combinatorial
construction on based on tableaus in the
end okay
and we don't know how to do this at the
moment for other varieties but for this
one it works really nicely because these
two these two things are very closely
related I mean this to this evaluation
this evaluation algorithm here there
there look amazingly close okay so yes
some indications of a relationship
between board around clip of wagging
drunk and the wedding ring
not so far does not have at the moment
does not have relation a connection okay
so okay so summary of this this part is
that so the representation theory here
of an oil bit can usually in in most of
the cases much better understood than
the representation theory of the
contouring of the orbit closure right
because here usually have some formulas
so actually all cases that we did we
interested in we have formulas for these
much business here and in many cases of
interest actually in the cases that we
are interested in these things are these
two rings are connected by this one by
by one fundamental invariant here and in
some cases we understand it better in
some cases it's harder to understand
this fundamentally where this is
actually related this is a this is a
related to this that was mentioned mep
so peter i mentioned this and it was the
quantum per minute i think people call
it quantum per minute in one talk anyway
so this is this is so this is sometimes
is a well known function but it also has
different every in many cases we have
difficulties understanding this this
money invariant so in case of power some
so the connection is very very very
close and the who is there is hope i
mean you might share it or not that
these are closely related in more
involved cases than just the power son
we just don't know yet exactly how close
alright so where is I mean so let me
maybe the last thing I should mention is
that there is where does there's one
more interesting insight we're hopeful
multiplicities actually could come from
and this is a paper by Larson and pink
from 1990 and it's not so often
mentioned when talking about GC t so if
you take so GL and it's acting and you
take H beings that say the stabilizer of
your point there just let me just remind
you these multiplicities are given just
by the dimensions of the H invariance in
this period
civets and so that's the pink studied
not actually this corner drinks of
orbits but they were interested in
studying what our ancient variants of
irreducible and and they studied in
higher generality so we take H being as
a subgroup of GL n but yeah so they'll
need some assumptions actually so should
be connected for example but under a
reasonable assumptions now your group H
is determined to isomorphism by all
these dimensions so if you know all
dimensions then you get H back and and
that's amazing so this means that if you
know all these multiplicities here in
your coin ring you actually get H back
and now if you but if you are in a
setting where H is a stabilizer of a
point that's characterized by its
stabilizer then you actually get that
point back all right so well there are
some caveats here but it's the general
idea right so for example if you are
studying orbit closures of these objects
here like determinant permanent is a
very amazing multiplication or power sum
or the monomial or matrix multiplication
terms or unit tensor they are all
characterized by their stabilizer so
this means that if you look if you know
all the dimensions here for these
objects then then all these
multiplicities would actually they will
characterize your your object alright so
and the conclusion is that and that is
very very very Wake conclusion here that
a strengthening of the theorem because
that's definitely an SI theorem doesn't
give you anything at this point but a
strengthening would could maybe yield
that your point is actually
characterized by its multiplicity all
right so and then that that would be a
hope to what's showing that then you can
then you can actually use my then you
might be able to show that in the in
these situations here that
multiplicities can always give you all
over bonds that there are so that's a
metonym but this is this is very vague
at this point but this is where where
hope comes from
there's some issues here so there are
first of all they're reasonable centers
and then this is up to group isomorphism
which is also no these are not
characterized by its stabilized up to
group isomorphism yeah it's also
submissive yeah it's connected semi
simple and this it is yeah
that is true but is this is not the case
here this was not mentioned in gc2b this
was the result with motivated me for the
multiplicity of station yes yes yes it's
not unfortunate that it's not in the
reference but now it's not hidden
anymore
alright so this needs a tiny bit of a
strengthening what I mean it might not
be tiny it's always a things are always
subtle in these business right so it is
a remarkable with that that is for sure
okay that that is for sure
so and yeah yeah so we hope I mean let
us hope that one can maybe push in this
direction and maybe actually get some
result on the lines that insert under
certain situations much procedure of
searches are guaranteed to give you
separations of there are separations but
this is very I mean that might be too
might not be true right all right so let
me just summarize what I told you
because yeah because there was some long
time ago all right so we in the
computation models that have padding
then we don't have of course
obstructions that proof stone of our
bonds the padding can be removed but
even if you remove the padding even a
very small explicit unpadded cases you
have situations where multiplicity
obstructions can be proved to be
stronger strictly stronger than of
course all selections where you can
separate with one or not the other
so one should probably go to
multiplicity obstructions and then so
much [ __ ] in the orbit are easier to
study they they come with a lot of
algebraic combinatorics that could be
understood and so on the connection to
to this to do much precision the over to
today is hopefully close right and works
actually for power sums is pretty close
for power sons and last and pink this
paper then gives hope that much
procedure obstructions could actually
work in the end
[Applause]
can you say about this larger to blow
when you're relating yes yes sir I mean
sure yeah I can I mean I can also yeah
sure you can tell you everything about
this yeah so that's the table so it's a
tableau tea I mean you know the type of
tea construction and there's a tableau s
construction so so there's a yeah so you
look at these and you look at the H
invariants all right so V lambda is
already given by tableaus and you just
look at the H invariance which in this
case here means that was low lambda has
at most M rows and then the agent
variance means that all numbers appear a
multiple of n many times right and then
and yeah and then you want to have it
being a linear combination so that the
symmetric group actually that is
invariant under the symmetric group and
those kind of tableaus you look at and
also not exactly the tableaus that
happen to be here but you can yeah I
mean I can show you I can show you the
explicit construction yeah you can it's
it's a combinatorial construction where
you where you try to simulate the
behavior here of this invariant so by by
splitting it up actually by splitting
this tableau up so there are some the
numbers on the stubble that the too many
Nam is there so for example each number
might appear more often then it can
actually then it should appear in T so
you have to split it up and and it's
just to simulate actually the behavior
of what happens in s and s things thinks
an S might happen that could not
actually happen in T but you can
actually see you can use blocks you can
put blocks in front of in front of s
that that will actually end up that at
the evaluation you will get exactly so
if you tu did exactly what what I should
do the shape is exactly you take the old
table you add along you add a long
rectangle that has a full number of rows
and you added in in an interesting way
so that will actually simulate the old
thing yes yes
can come up start setting up for one
final question okay so the the old
algorithm would be would would do a a
depth first search on a on a lot of
different table lows and the new
algorithm is using a sophisticated
caching mechanism so the the which my
student Dooley and are are developed by
having I mean so he understood what this
what the original algorithm did and in
this specific case of the Chow variety a
very specific caching mechanism can be
used to speed this up for evaluating a
highest weight vector at a point on the
chopper AIA T so if you have the travel
right you're part of homogeneous
nearfall so if you want to evaluate at
that on a point on that variety then
there are non-trivial algorithms that
are very it faster by using a lot of
space actually lot of disk space they
very add much faster than then you would
usually do this on on on a different
different varieties yeah but but
basically cancel the cost of a lot of
storage space and before we didn't have
any use of we didn't use any storage
space and he cleverly says let's just
use these Spiga bytes of storage space
and then this is much much faster
all right so let's thank Christian again